if you don't mind taking a minute you
know the part the way you explain it i
asked this question who was i
interviewing the the crime uh detective
from uk
uh uh
paul milleri yeah paul millery yeah from
uk who his job was to go interview these
guys and find out what it is and i asked
him the question
about nature versus nurture because you
know sometimes you're in school we had
this one kid who was six years old who
liked to throw dogs out the window from
fourth floor and like
you gotta have something off to do that
at six years old and he was always a
little weird right when he would do
certain things so explain the nurture
versus nature of somebody who is born
who eventually ends up becoming a
murderer committing major crimes of
taking someone's life is it nurture is
it nature
well um i think people are are skipping
a very important component when you talk
about nature versus nurture it's
actually a combination of bio psycho and
social so
you have a certain propensity or
potentiality with your genetics you're
born with the abilities to do certain
things and the inabilities to do other
things
but your psychology and your personality
are the filter through which you
experience life
so your socialization is actually
filtered through your psychology and
personality
and then your
personality is actually made
through
the millions of little private decisions
you make in your own brain so that's how
you affect
how life affects you and so
the way i like to summarize it is
genetics loads the gun
personality and psychology aims it
and your experiences pull the trigger so
unless you have that
perfect storm of all three aspects
you won't get somebody who's going to go
out and kill
somebody you know they've done twin
studies where we're one twin who's got
the same genetics identical twins is in
a is in a difficult situation and
his parents are suffering and they're
sacrificing and they're not even getting
enough food right because they're
feeding their kids and that one kid says
i
i love my parents i i i see how they
suffer for me when i grow up i want to
make sure they want for nothing i want
to take care of them and the other twin
says are you kidding me
they don't even give us what we deserve
we deserve better they're failures i
hate them
and
that's the same genetics but the
decisions that the one twin made in his
own mind instead of pushing away from
the dark side he embraces it and that's
the negative spin he puts on everything
he experiences and i think that's why
you get people who ultimately go down
the road of being a killer or a serial
killer or a rapist or a zero rapist
because they made these tiny little
decisions in their brains that they're
more important than other people
so so okay so i like the way you put it
you said
genetics loads the gun personality and
psychology aims it but then your
experiences pulls the trigger right so
okay so now let's we just had the uh
kyle rittenhouse uh case by the way 10
minutes before we did the interview i'm
sure you saw that being in the world not
guilty not guilty not guilty
so what is it in his case okay so that's
a current event that right now everybody
around the world is talking about
absolutely what how would you classify
his case
well to me the some of the the
circumstances that came out in the trial
that people didn't know beforehand the
fact is that he did not purchase that
weapon he had a friend purchased it but
he couldn't wait to get his hands on it
he wanted to feel more powerful he felt
helpless and he wanted something that
was going to give him that power and
then
the the the riots and the uprising and
the protests gave him the opportunity to
be called upon to be powerful with this
weapon and so this is why we don't give
guns to 17 year olds this is why we have
rules you can't buy it until you're 18.
now if it's supervised with an adult you
can operate one earlier if you know how
to do it and you could do it safely
but
he did not have those circumstances but
in this case because of the way the
trial
fell out because of the way the evidence
was or wasn't turned over some of these
things were not given to the jury and
and the charges of him illegally
possessing a weapon were dropped by the
judge they were they were thrown out
and that sort of undermined the entire
case but if you look at it behaviorally
this is a young man
now who was a boy at the time a teenager
who
felt powerless
and that weapon in his hand gave him
power
so what did he do he went out to
basically exercise that power in a
situation where he felt justified to do
it so in his brain he said and and there
was actually
quotes of him saying watching protests
earlier on and violence earlier on
saying oh man i wish i had my gun right
this is something that he had thought
about a long time
but he put himself in that opportunity
so that he could use that gun and no
matter what somebody else did
i believe that this is something that he
was destined to do he wanted to do this
his personality drove him to be in a
position where he could pull that
trigger
and that was an irresponsible thing at
the very least for him to do
i believe that
that he went out there
because he wanted to actually exercise
that power and unfortunately ended in
the death of two people a serious injury
to a third
i don't know
all the facts and circumstances because
obviously i wasn't there so i don't know
if this jury's verdict was was proper or
not
but i do know there are going to be
people that are very displeased with it
thinking that it was literally just
because of biases unfortunately i think
what it was was because of the legal way
the the legalities and the laws and how
they are enforced in that particular
state i don't believe that the jury got
it wrong i think that unfortunately the
case
fell apart because of when and how the
evidence was presented so if you like
this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you